Hello everyone,
this is Paul and you are watching the
lane focus channel.
Today I'm going to talk about language
learning edge number three,
and that edge is meditation,
so you might be thinking,
what the heck does meditation have to do
with language learning?
Well,
it has a couple of big benefits that can
really affect your results,
so I wanted to share it with you.
It's something that I do all the time,
but I want to make clear that this is
not religious meditation.
If you have your own religion and you're
worried that maybe this is Buddhism or
some other religion that uses
meditation.
No,
I'm not teaching you that.
I'm just talking about how to relax your
body and also your mind so that you can
focus and learn more efficiently.
Alright,
well let me talk about some of the
benefits that meditation has for your
language learning.
One of them is that it puts you in an
ideal learning state,
puts you in something called an Alpha
state,
which means that your brain waves are
moving at a slower speed than they are
when you normally go throughout your
day.
When you normally go about your day,
you are in a Beta state in your brain,
waves are moving.